und auch mich hat ein thema heute bewegt
oder ehrlich gesagt fassungslos werden
lassen und das waren angela merkel
ursula von der leyen hier sieht man es
siege zu will frau merkel die hand geben
und es endet im kuriosesten handschlag
aller zeiten die hand so frau trinkt sie
mit beiden händen
ich habe mir das wirklich ich habe mich
wirklich gefragt als ich mich dass ich
mir das angesehen habe möchte ich solche
spitzenpolitiker haben und ich muss bei
allem respekt für angela merkel und
ursula von der leyen sagen nein jetzt
noch so sich zu begegnen nicht mehr als
die hand zu geben sondern die faust und
dann beide hände beide sind übrigens
geimpft und das ist natürlich auch
doppelt und jetzt deswegen meine
forderung wir brauchen endlich wieder
politik kam mit handschlagqualität
also ausnahmsweise liebe [ __ ] muss ich
die uneingeschränkt recht geben das gibt
mir die gelegenheit mich ganz herzlich
zu bedanken ich bin mit großer freude
nach berlin gekommen und hier in dieser
runde der besten talkshow im
deutschsprachigen raum teilzunehmen toll
gemachte trotz meiner teilnahme was kann
man da sagen das ist einfach das
sinnbild diese verkrampften verklemmten
politik wo sogar die protagonistinnen
diese politik die übersicht verloren
habe und über ihre eigenen corona
sie wissen gar nicht mehr welchen
handshake oder um es mit augenaufschlag
machen muss das hat natürlich auch eine
art kindergarten qualität obwohl wir dem
kindergarten hier nicht zu nahe treten
wollen ich lese gerade auch im deutschen
bundestag sind jetzt ganz große fragen
werden diskutiert wer nämlich wo im saal
sitzt wo sitzt die fdp wo sitzt die cdu
wo sitzt die partei mit den drei
buchstaben der name man nicht
aussprechen
ich würde sagen die deutsche politik wie
übrigens auch die schweizerische im
zustand einer fortschreitenden
infantilisierung kann man da so
zusammenfasst aber die
andere frage ist auch über dem ruhm kam
es zu dieser situation da gibt es zwei
mögliche gründe das erste ist angst
angela merkel hat angst sich anzustecken
wir wissen angela merkel ist kona
ängstlich aber angst sollte nie ein
guter ratgeber seien weder in der
wirtschaft noch in der politik und die
an möglichkeit ist erziehung aber ich
möchte mich nach zwei jahren pandemie
nicht erziehen lassen von einem
politiker aber ich muss auch sagen für
mich ist das eigentlich nicht das größte
corona ärgern ist dieser woche es ist am
ende die entscheidung von zwei
individuen und wir fordern ja auch mehr
eigenverantwortung beim kampf gegen die
pandemie ihren das ist natürlich angela
merkels eigene entscheidung bei ihnen
politisches statement also ist die
bundeskanzlerin natürlich wie die
bundeskanzlerin begrüßt ist er nicht
mehr nur das individuum zurückzuführen
das lustigste fand ich habe benedikt sie
berühren sich ja komplett also die faust
dann von frau merkel dann mit beiden
händen dem ursula von der leyen diese
pause in die hand das ist die kurioseste
der kurier herr einschränkt ist ja das
muss ich sagen ich verstehe den aufreger
überhaupt nicht weil es ist einfach der
alltag den wir im moment alle haben ich
habe das ständig im freundeskreis dass
leute sagen gebe ich jetzt erhalte ich
den fuß hin oder halte ich die hand hin
oder mache ich den hier in kanada aber
es werden auch die bussi machen und so
ja aber es ist doch einfach nur diese
übergangszeit die wir jetzt gerade haben
ich glaube dass überhaupt kein
politisches statement die kanzlerin ist
halt vorsichtig oder höflich weil sie
halt nicht weiß wie sieht es denn ursula
von der leyen und jeder weitere entlang
ermittler hoffen auf sie zu als ursachen
kam mit dem handschlag so und sie hat
ihn abgelehnt ich glaube gerätselt jetzt
alles ordnung wenn die merkel kein
handschlag machen will ich meinen corona
ist ja noch nicht vorbei sorry also ich
weiß du siehst das anders aber wir haben
steigende instanzen lettland hat schon
wieder lockdown wir haben den euro über
neue variante in großbritannien also mal
abwarten dass der merkel den steigender
infektionszahlen muss mehr sagen es ist
ja heutzutage kann man sich schon fragen
ob die infektion seien jemals der
richtige maß wert waren und man sich
lieber die becken genommen die
intensivbetten plus wenn man die
altersgruppen anschaut ich habe die
letztens durchgeschaut dann sieht man
klar und es stimmt es gibt auch ein
anstieg bei über 80 jährigen und das ist
natürlich nur wohlhabende gruppe da
werden wir maßnahmen treffen müssen aber
ich fordere deswegen er schon seit
langem den freedom day für deutschland
deshalb ja hab ich übrigens sagen ja
auch alle das hat gar nichts mit kronen
zu tun ist sagen ja ganz viele virologen
oder experten sagen wir sollen uns gar
nicht die hände schütteln weil wir uns
ja alles mögliche einfallen
nicht mal zu freunden kann doch auch
ganz schön voll durch zeit ihr leben
vollkommen am thema vorbei was wir hier
vor was wir hier sehen ist einfach
absolute unehrlichkeit und doppelmoral
wir wissen alle dass diese ganzen
politiker mit diesem mit der hybris
rumlaufen dass sie vorbilder für uns
sein sollen sie wollten mit dem
erzieherischen zweck sie glauben sie sie
glauben sie müssen sie müssen vorbilder
seien sobald die kameras weg sind sitzen
die eng beieinander und schüttelt sich
selbstverständlich die hände frau merkel
menk weiß die kameras auf sie gerichtet
und will das image vorbildfunktion
bienen beim g7-gipfel über war das ein
großes ärgernis dass die ganzen
politiker zwei meter auseinander
fotografiert wurden sogar sogar solange
die presse dabei waren alle auch mit
maske kaum waren die kameras max saßen
sie alle eng beieinander da ist eine
doppelmoral da ist und die doppelmoral
die dahinter steckt ist wer bin ich
gefährlich nämlich was so angedeutet hat
die politiker bilden sich immer mehr ein
dass sie zu unseren erzieherin werden
soll es geht um sie müssen ständig
vorbilder sein müssen die soll
anständige politik machen die sollen
nicht mehr die soll nicht vorbilder in
ihrer lebensführung für mich sein sie
verkennen die verwechseln personen mit
amt das ist schon mal ein riesenproblem
ebenfalls auf frau merkel ist doch kein
vorbild für mich für mich wie kommen wir
da hin dass mit welchem anspruch kommt
überhaupt dahin uns irgendwie belehren
zu wollen ich glaube ich glaube dass wir
da auf einem ganz abschüssigen
piste sind wenn wir unseren wenn wir
unsere politiker zu unseren erzieherin
machen ich geb dir völlig recht aber
diese woche gibt es doch wirklich
wichtigeres zu diskutieren also heute
hat die mpk getagt und jetzt läuft am 25
november die epidemische lage aus und
die ministerpräsidenten fordern einen
neuen rechtsrahmen wie sieht dieser
rechtsrahmen aus welche rechte wird uns
zurück geben welche rechte wird er uns
nicht zurückgeben das ist doch die viel
spannendere frage als ob sich frau von
der leyen und frau merkel und die hand
geben oder nicht oder wie also das finde
ich heute am tag der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz tatsächlich
die entscheidende frage der
entscheidende punkt ist natürlich
wollte das mitwachsen der
fassungslosigkeit wie sich hier eine art
longo wie in der politik gestellt wir
haben longo wieder in der politik die
regierungen können nicht loslassen
ich sehe das auch in unserem land ich
sehe es in anderen ländern ich komme
gerade aus großbritannien ich bin
vermutlich die neue virus variante die
er ist eingetroffen ist ich habe durch
durch visaprobleme gut den container
schaffte durchgegangen mit allen
möglichen anti mit dem biologischen
maßnahmen in großbritannien wo ja völlig
falsch geschrieben wird was diesem land
geht wenn man hier die zeitungen
aufschlägt man ja großbritannien sein
wie in einem schwarzen loch politische
antimaterie versunken oder im kanal
zumindest denen geht es gut die haben ja
an den landesgrenzen strengere
kontrollen aber in vendig also im land
sehr große freiheit boris jones sehr
beliebt während bei uns die regierung
und das ist mein eindruck auch in
deutschland oder in der schweiz fast
noch etwas schlimmer die regierungen
können nicht loslassen sie haben
irgendwie zu viel vom job der macht von
der droge vom opium der macht gegossen
das ist nicht mehr glauben jetzt dass
sie kollektiv dafür verantwortlich sind
im bundestag oder in den parlamenten uns
daran zu hindern krank zu werden sie
haben also die ganze verantwortung an
sich gerissen und dahinter steckt
natürlich ein misstrauensvotum sie
trauen uns nicht zu eigentlich die
wichtigste entscheidung die
gegen standesregeln these ist es so dass
ja vielleicht auch die süchtig geworden
sind nach der kontrolle wurden nach ich
weiß nicht ob die sich da ist es wichtig
sind nach kontrolle also ich finde halt
zum beispiel ich möchte zum beispiel
nicht krank werden ja und natürlich kann
man sagen wir müssen die verantwortung
selber haben nur ich habe ja nur
verantwortung über mich selbst und wenn
ich irgendwo hingehe hab ich halt kein
bock dass da sich corona kranke um mich
herum sind und mich anpusten mit ihren
viren so also ich kann schon den kern
verstehen dass man sagt wir wollen
irgendwie unser volk schützen vor
krankheit deshalb weiß ich nicht ob das
jetzt im machthungrig kyte ist sich zu
freuen daran dass man den bürgern was
verbietet was soll s denen dann bringen
was haben sie denn davon ich glaube
nicht also sollten das gewählt wie
freude ich glaube da ist niemand wir
müssen macht ansammeln aber ich glaube
es gibt so n fast unbewussten tendenz
oder eine ein baby
physikalisches gesetz das macht immer
sich ausbreiten will und im moment wurde
der politik die gelegenheit gibt ihre
macht zu zentralisieren wird es sehr
schwer lässt sie sehr schwer davon loser
ist kein böser wille daher das ist fast
ein automatismus fast ein physikalisches
gesetz macht sieht macht an und wir
wären wir kommen in der situation dass
du sagst longo wird dass die politik
sich aufmacht uns in unserem leben
hineinzuregieren in die kleinsten winkel
unseres privatlebens und das viel
schlimmere ist noch keiner kann man sich
darüber empören oder man kann auch
widerstand leisten in gewissen grad ich
umarme und mir nicht vorschreiben lassen
sich jemand begrüße das schlimme ist wir
gewöhnen uns dran wir gewöhnen uns dran
und es wird ist wird die nächste krise
kommen es wird die übernächste krise
kommen und bis dahin sind wir moralisch
klein gemacht wir sind so wie sie zu
ihren leidensdruck als ich weil ich
fühle mich gar nicht mehr so rein
regiert ich meine ja wir müssen jetzt
noch maske tragen und wir müssen wir ein
paar tests machen und das stäbchen in
die nase stecken aber was ist denn jetzt
gerade so schlimm also du sagst wir
brauchen den freedom day ja aber was
genau wie habt ihr denn jetzt so ist
auch wer allerdings sehen
leiharbeiter geben ich kann nur eine
sache sagen für mich ist es maske tragen
definitiv nicht einfach mal eben ich
muss ein bisschen maske trage ich mache
mir wissen starb für mich ist maske
tragen so eine unverschämte
einschränkung meiner freiheit sich bis
heute sage ich finde es unverschämt dass
wieder jemand vorschreibt vor allem
jetzt bei den zahlen und beim im status
[Musik]